now getting sounds into grits was a bit
of an interesting process you see we
really didn't have funds to actually get
a sound designer to make anything for us
so we had to act like a scrappy little
startup this actually started at the
beginning where do we get our sounds
well thanks to the indie gaming boom of
2009 there's actually tons and tons of
resources out there for independent game
developers to go get sounds for free so
we employed that strategy now when you
do this be very clear of what you're
actually getting most sounds on the
internet actually follow with some sort
of weird licensing restriction either
Creative Commons or attribution or
something along those lines so when you
grab your salmon make sure you
understand how you have to credit it
usually it comes with something the
second thing you have to worry about is
when you grab a lot of sounds from the
internet that were made from different
designers on different sound boards they
probably aren't very unified which means
that they're not going to sound cohesive
inside of your game for this you
actually need to take your sounds
through a post-processing tool personal
favorite of mine is one called gold wave
I've been using it probably since about
1998 it's free and easy to grab on
windows inside of these tools you
basically want to cut your sounds trim
your sounds and make it sound as though
everything is in the same environment
case in point there's a lot of little
gotchas out there when you're trying to
get good content into a game and sounds
are really tricky to do so do your due
diligence post-process your sounds make
awesome